du gewinnst ein haus muss fünf personen
mitnehmen die einzige bedingung ist aber
dass es nur youtuber sein dürfen wen
würdest du mitnehmen
hallo ich meine freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft exit auf
dem server und zwar ist dabei heute max
hallo wir wissen max hallo krankhafter
sehr leise weil wir beide bei uns in der
halle und das ist schon viel
sie sind brüder und max brod und lukas
hässig die nachnamen gesagt weißt dass
du so nachnamen gesagt scheiße ok musst
du zensieren wir müssen wenn das
vergisst dann suchen zwischen dollar in
facebook
das war heftig und richtig angst vor dem
leben
erst dann kann es kurz was ich jetzt
mache und zwar schnappe ich mir meinen
schoko wenn ich das mal finde ist dass
jemals das ist hundertprozentig hier
wieder mainz hatten bei dir in einem
kommentar gelesen dass du deinen chocobo
irgendwo stehen lassen hass im netz oder
so irgendwie 3.0 oder so steht dem
neckar jetzt irgendwie am net a porter
herumstehen lassen habe ich gehört
zumindest ein portal
ja das habe ich den habe ich gelesen in
deiner hundertsten folge unter den
hunderten folge wenn man sowas hat jetzt
für mich nichts damit zu tun
ich gucke einfach mal ich aktualisieren
wir die ganzen kommentare bekannt ja ist
doch die könnten nicht tobago wo wir
stehen
das ist der ist weg ich kümmere mich
auch gar nicht um den sieg aber ein paar
kommentare ich wollte heute eigentlich
sondern
eine reise machen aber wir gehen halt
wieder auf kommentare anwalt echt ein
paar richtig geile angekommen sind hier
also ich hab den kommentar gefunden von
domains auch wenns grad nichts mit dem
inhalt des videos zu tun hat aber hab
gerade ins ensemble folge gesehen dass
den jockey 3.0 noch beim leiter vorsteht
wurde es bei der wir gehen schoko pro
folge abgestellt als nur für den fall
dass du suchen solltest
ich weiß wo okay das ist okay allerdings
wollen wir müssen halt wie gesagt nur
ein bisschen flüstern also wir werden
jetzt einfach so weitergehen wie bisher
ja aber das lenkt euch das lenkt die
spannung auf und ja also soll ich mal
die erste frage vom hessischen trebur
vorlesen
ja klar kann es machen ist eine richtig
geile von at night rex und zwar du
gewinnst ein haus muss fünf personen
mitnehmen die einzige bedingung ist aber
dass es nur youtuber sein dürfen wen
würdest du mitnehmen
es trifft nur youtuber sein ja das ist
ein affront für fünf lustig ist dass man
für den partner aussuchen
also wenn ich ein haus sagen wir mal ich
hab im haus und wie die fr gesagt ich
darf noch youtuber mit einem also auf
jeden dich weil ich dich halt so als
einzigen so richtig richtig kenne
wir kennen uns ja ich vergesse der
aufnahme hat unseren wohnort gesagt brot
statt
hier muss jetzt auch zensieren und auch
unseren am anfang wenn wir beginnen wir
viele informationen um euch eine falte
für falsche fährte zu locken
also fünf personen ich bin eine ju max
ist auf jeden fall dabei
dann also ich weiß jetzt muss ich
unbedingt mit den leuten auf youtube was
zu tun haben oder einfach nur mit mit
wen ich mitnehmen würde eine einzige
bedingung ist dass das youtuber sein so
ist wo er dann auch wenig sympathisch
finde ich würde auf jeden fall
ich zähle es mal sechs cap sind ist sind
es eigene da die finde ich mega
sympathisch die kopie zeit locker zwei
jahren jetzt mittlerweile die würde ich
auf jeden auch mitnehmen weil ich die
echt mega cool finde aber seine sondern
indien reise gemacht was ich halt auch
ich möchte auf jeden fall auch mal nach
indien reisen nach indien ist ja genau
das habe ich war mal mitnehmen darüber
geredet also indien ist natürlich eine
große sache aber jetzt schon gesagt wenn
du also fünf mitnehmen das heißt noch 3
2 doch das sind diesen 26 cap deshalb du
musst kommen mit reinster des mit reinem
dass du weißt wie er aussieht
madonna würde ich aber gleich mitnehmen
er wirkte da will ich mitnehmen und dann
noch kaffee oder tee das glaube ich
ich glaube ja denn wer das haus ziemlich
geile den quoten russen ein vater war ja
gut das muss der hält sich auch gar
nicht so an wie nasse hände hört sich an
wie in geilo einfach jeden fall noch
aber ein geiler vergessen hab ich
irgendwie noch fried sachen habe die ich
mir zum craften kann
und sonst würde ich sagen kannst du ich
habe hier eine sehr eindeutige frage die
man überhaupt nicht falsch verstehen
kann was würdest du machen wenn du für
einen tag eine frau wird eine frau wäre
die frage nehmen wenn ich max jeder weiß
das mal machen würde und zwar in die
küche gehen und kochen
frage das stimmt die ist hier ist eine
frage
die hast du aber eigentlich soweit ich
weiß in deiner letzten verantwortbaren
kommt wieder ein neues projekt und
welches hast du ein bisschen was
angesprochen oder ja jetzt in der folge
die heute kamen genau also genau gestern
also hier ist aber noch eine frage oder
willst du etwas anderes sagen ja also es
einfach die folge von gestern meldete
dass er sehen nein es wird etwas neues
kommen und es wird geil auf jeden fall
und zwar fragt rebecca was sind
allgemein deine lieblings geschäfte also
wirst du am liebsten jetzt sagen wir mal
wenn wir mal kategorien aus klamotten
und ja irgendeinen also klamotten
bestelle ich eigentlich am meisten
wirklich ich würde ich sagen im internet
aber ich beschäftige internet und heftig
im laden weil ich im internet halt immer
sehr viele sachen findet dies teilweise
in den läden gar nicht gibt also da gibt
es dann den wie frontlineshop asphalt
gold mir bist du dort an die jungs
verteilt
das ist max laden ein fertiger text weil
sie nicht dann auch viel
ja klar jesus aber ich überlege gerade
ob hier lebten gibt die eventuell es nur
hier gibt also er hat zu leben die halt
so sachen haben die so die jugend trägt
also wieder mal in mainz teil so was ich
halt immer so an hab so string tangas
und jeden fall das unsichtbare träger
belassen
ich wette ich fange ich habe wieder
etwas vergessen was ihr was ich
eigentlich brauche für diese reise ich
habe alles mit also ich werde auf jeden
fall einfach laufen gemüse halt für mein
schoko 9.2 wo gehst du gerne essen also
oder was was isst du gern sagen wir
abstrahieren wir es ein bisschen also
ich gehe sehr gerne alex das gibt's ja
auch mittlerweile irgendwie überall rein
elektrisch dann gehe ich wirklich
dennoch gerne subway auf jeden fall aber
ich liebe auch ich liebe burger king so
halte aber akin ja so toll finde ich da
echt ist bei mir an oberster stelle
okay das ist ein üblicher chicken
teriyaki orchester ich liebte ihn auch
also titel wenn ihr auch zuschicken
kariuki crew gehörten den einstieg mit
handy auf brot und animas tat so sein
start als ob ich schwöre auf mein leben
ohne gras dicker ohne gras sei nur wie
krass oder krass aber für mich ist das
eins zu eins das ist echt ohne kraft
ohne krass und kraft
hier ist eine gute frage und zwar was
hältst du von fan videos du kennst ja
bestimmt oder diese ganzen fan-video die
ab und zu über erstellt werden
ja natürlich also da gibt es erstmal
keine viele verschiedene sachen gibts ja
best ofs dann gibts die gibts ja das
alles mögliche gibt es wenn man das
jetzt wo ich habe auch gar nicht die
rüstung überhaupt an um hier irgendwie
zu kämpfen und irgendwie sind in diesem
was ich bin sauer
aber wir sind auch über all die ganzen
kisten sind glaube ich ja diesen alle
schon teilweise geflutet bluetooth nur
die obersten zwei etagen dinge als dj da
was nicht stimmt nicht überlebst du ja
ich überlebe ich habe mich eingebuddelt
junge ja ich habe die falsche richtung
an und ich bin direkt in diesen
heftigsten in dieser heftigsten türme
die gehen alle nach unten
okay ich bin direkt einfach
durchgefallen durch löcher und war
direkt ganz unten sollte ob sich nur
noch ob sie das habe ich jetzt einfach
ihre aus läuft bei mir egal
gut wasser der frage und zwar glaube
also hier zumindest eine frage und
relativ weit von einer von der ich weiß
dass sie sowas macht und zwar diese fan
videos diese zusammenschnitte oder so
das team für mich richtig geil ich finde
das auch so heftiger zusammenschnitte
sind echt richtig geil ich weiß jetzt
schon mehr da irgendwie gemacht ja das
ist wie youtube chrysler fix kowski
richtig richtig so heftig und das finde
ich finde es mal kind auch richtige
motivation wenn man einfach so leute
sieht von dem halt mit bekommt so dass
sie die videos gucken und das dann halt
auch feiern und dann halt auch wieder
irgendwie zeigen durch ihre videos und
ich finde das richtig geil ich war ja
auch irgendwie wie du und ich habe das
iwes gefeiert nicht
oder ich weiß aber auf jeden fall was du
meinst dann fragt diese defizite im
allgemein fan görtz bzw fan arzt
das ist eigentlich genau dasselbe oder
es einfach es zeigt einfach dass das
tier das die zuschauer interesse an
einem heim und ist einfach mega geil
wenn man sowas sieht oder ja das finde
ich auch also ich würde also auf jeden
fall nur die er zuständig sind allgemein
videos die für ein gemacht werden
richtig richtig geil ich feiere
aber als ich sie jetzt einfach mal die
andere rüstung an
man stellt mit der fristen kann man
nicht so gut reisen wie wenn ich jetzt
die anderen ihr nehmen
aber wenn jetzt so fanfiction also das
mag ich gar nicht das finde ich habe
hier eine frage gefunden von kevin
wiederkehr die im die pasta latif gut
zum anfang unsere folge haben wir so ein
bisschen quatschen über ihnen unser und
war fragt er wenn du jetzt mit einem
last minute flug wegfliegen könntest
wohin würdest du fliegen und einfach
losgehen könnte ist alles hier sitzen
und es ist eine sache die ich mir
letztens in letzter zeit sehr oft
gedanken machen und zwar möchte ich nach
dem abi habe ich lange überlegt ob ich
das studiere oder ob ich irgendwo
hinfahre und jetzt letztendlich bin ich
immer mehr so auf dem trip so dass ich
einfach du weißt so dass ich das mit
felix machen möchte wir beide wollen
halt immer mehr halt quasi nach dem abi
sonst klar gewonnen das ist die einzige
zeit ist wo du wirklich so frei bist
mehr oder weniger das heißt wo du so
wirklich sonderreise irgendwie wenn du
irgendwo hin reise wird zu antreten
kannst deswegen haben uns gedacht dass
wir dann eventuell auch sowas machen da
steht natürlich mittlerweile auch vor
der entscheidung was ist denn eigentlich
mit youtube in dazu langem ich laufen
kann
also ich denke wenn ich jetzt ein
minute flug hätte und ich durfte mir
etwas aussuchen wo ich hin fliege würde
ich also auf unserer reise werden
hundertprozentig man sich halt so die
worte ca aussuchen aber ich denke es
wird hundertprozentig auf jeden fall
neuseeland drauf sein
neuseeland relativ exotisch eigentlich
nie gesehen hat richtig geil habe ich
richtig bock darauf diese und ein kumpel
von mir war da jetzt fünf monate cea und
hab mir fotos gezeigt das ist so geil da
alles richtig schön krass also
eigentlich ist es ja noch so ein
bisschen so alte mentalität dass man
sagt sie mein pferd nur so mittelmeeres
mittelmeerländer und das ist ja immer
mehr so gekommen
diese bei mir ist auch der geschmack
richtig komisch ich würde richtig gern
länder sehen wir neue seen und halt so
exotisch sodann dann halt sex oder strip
oder halt ich würde halt auch mega gern
mal so einfach nach amerika zu sehen wie
das da so ist die komplette gegensätze
ich mag halt relativ viel da hier ist
jetzt keine frage gewesen und zwar wie
alt warst du als du dein erstes youtube
video gemacht hast also erstmal keine
ein stück von mir sofort stehen hier
ungefähr 55 oder von alter glaub ich 15
oder 16
ich bin gerade selbst nicht so sicher
echt krass hatte zuletzt den kanal schon
lange bevor du lust gelegt hast das war
gut wir gar nicht konkret ein als bayer
konkurrent elpida das war ganz ganz
lange geschichte du gehst du zuerst mal
gelesen was hältst du von dem gerücht
dass der entwickler von flexibel suizid
begangen haben soll also ist
wahrscheinlich quatsch aber dass man
überhaupt gerüchte in die welt setzt
dass jemand sich selbst umgebracht hat
das wort über den er auch mal verbreitet
das war mega krasses über den verbreitet
wurde weil denen youtuber ist denise
herrmann weiß was mir gefällt ist mein
schoko und hierzu gut wenn ich doch so
weit weg fliegen und dann mit einem
spiegel zurückgehen dann kommt mein job
oder gar niemand muss geladen sein egal
ich immer mit caps dann dann sollte er
sich da eben bei yahoo
einfach mal eben zurück gleich wieder
zurück
nee also über den er wird das halt mal
verbreitet dass den angeblich einen
autounfall gehabt haben soll
und er irgendwie tote und so die videos
sind trotzdem gekommen einen tag lang
war das so aber er war halt echt auch
den ganzen tag irgendwie nicht in
whatsapp online und nicht in skype und
facebook gepostet und so und dann war
der abend wieder in bei uns in der skype
com china europe konnte wohl auch immer
so einfach so geschrieben wird zuließ
dass und dann kann man den er dazu und
dann alles ich hatte mit ri die wirklich
so krank wir wollten ihn so anrufen
lässt nicht rangegangen und alles so wie
hat nicht richtig angst weil weißt du
wenn du erfährst dass er so einfach
stellt er ein auto im vergab das team
also erhält vor allem die ganzen
menschenmassen und sonders werden durch
die medien und alles gegangen und
halbwaisen nicht also ich finde sowas
nicht mehr so etwas in die welt setzt
aber das ist kacke versteht nicht und
ich habe mich auch letzten mal
vorgestellt ist eigentlich ein bisschen
ein kleines wunder dass wenn man das
jetzt mal irgendwie so statistisch
betrachtet dass du nun youtube noch nie
was ernstes passiert ist oder
also ich hab noch nie der fall was
mitbekommen dass irgendwie ist ein
deutscher youtuber sie irgendwie
komplett ausgefallen ist von youtube
weil ich halt irgendwie ein unfall oder
so was hatte also das finde ich
eigentlich relativ krass youtuber leben
sicherer
müssen jetzt eine statistik machen wie
viele erstmal generell nicht so sagen
dass youtube sich hp show geschlagen
nein sondern der statistik also es gibt
ja auch viele also es muss als nicht
wahr sein dass man sich irgendwie ein
bein bricht und dadurch ist die stimme
auch beschädigt und dann kann man keine
videos mehr aufnehmen
es kann ja auch einfach so sein dass ich
kenne das von einem aus amerika der
hatte depressionen und hat dann gesagt
er hört auf mit youtube oder so aber die
kanäle existieren
ich würde echt mega lang her und es gibt
halt schon ich denke gerade wenn leute
sich dazu entschließen videos im
internet hochzuladen hat man hier ein
gewisses selbstvertrauen mehr oder
weniger so selbstbewusstsein weil ich
denke nicht dass leute die total
abgeschottet von der gesellschaft leben
dann auf einmal sich die mut fassen
videos im internet hochzuladen und
einfach so in die kamera zu quatschen
wenn sie es so quasi nicht mehr können
nichts gegen die leute aber ich denke
dass auch menschen die halt einfach
zufrieden mit sich selbst sind ich meine
es gibt keine youtube-videos weil es
irgendwie mega mega traurig ist und
erzählt wie kaká sein leben das ist
möchte auch keine anschauen deswegen
denke ich dass das man man man ist quasi
am gesündesten wenn man wirklich sich
selbst akzeptiert und halt quasi ich bin
schon nix an der stadt vorbei geflogen
ich behindert
und ich denke das ist einfach ein großer
faktor ist natürlich einfach so viel ich
sag mal glücksmomente hat die einem
natürlich gesundheitlich auch
weiterhelfen dass weder sogar gesagt ins
lachen hält ja gesund und alles also ich
denke dass auf jeden fall was seine
statistik jetzt nicht bewegen doch dies
gut und tut es gut ich bin vom institut
für marktforschung und was ich hier als
hab ich auf einmal an das fazit für
marktforschung kann als nieten
ich saß also ist auf jeden fall
schneller nicht ab wenn mein schiff
drückt das geht ein rechtsklick residenz
toll jetzt habe ich ihnen die reise
gemacht als einziger sie gekriegt 5x ik
lizenzen und sonst einfach
ich wollte eigentlich weniger elektrik
das scannen der tauschen oder wenn
irgendjemand anders da ist wechselt dann
brauchen wir doch immer wieder oder gar
nicht machen so eine sehr gute frage
hier von maik w
du willst ja die party folge stoppen die
die frage ist also was willst du machen
wenn du im neuen projekt früh durch
einen bären sterben würdest ganz
allgemeine frage ich gleich denke dann
würde ich auf jeden fall das video
beenden wird rumschreit oder würden
gerüchte umgehen dass ich wahrscheinlich
selbst mut gemacht hätte in der schule
für deine eigene beerdigung
zusammengefasst
das ist ein projekt das kann natürlich
sehr sehr schnell vorbei sein also
natürlich wir haben ja gesagt wenn man
tot ist ist man raus und ja wenn ich
dann theoretisch von einem bären
angegriffen werde dann ist es halt so
dann passiert ist halt dann bin ich halt
raus und dann gehe ich mich damit
zufrieden also jeder der quasi bei dem
projekt mitmacht gibt sich quasi damit
ab findet sich damit ab dass das ganze
quasi sehr sehr schnell vorbei sein kann
also sollte der zuschauer ist merkt man
schnell die frage auf ob die voll
geschäftsfrau bei meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat dass eine
bewertung der themen könnt ihr bei
twitter schreiben
täterbeschreibung cry und kraft da steht
auch in den beschreibungen drin
ja und sonst will ich sagen wir können
eigentlich schon mal ankündigen oder das
im sommer wahrscheinlich einige coole
videos kommen werden wenn wir zusammen
urlaub sind wir zusammen hoch
sind dann wird auf luca film wieder
einiges kommen so vom streit und so was
alles aber sonst würde ich sagen freunde
wie den morgen wieder da kommen dann ab
morgen folgen mit cash glaube ich zwei
und bald wird auch noch paar coole
sachen geben könnt euch darauf freuen
und sich sagen macht's gut